fortnite chapter 2 season 4 is upon us
and we're going to dive into the most
important changes players can experience
with the current marvel theme
fortnite has grown infamous for its
outrageous and daring live events
such as breaking the game and deleting
everything in chapter 1 into a black
hole
in fortnight there have been plenty of
events like these usually near the end
of the season to give it a proper
send-off
now most recently we had the device
which set the stage for the splashdown
chapter
by flooding the entire map however the
transition to the marvel season has been
less
grand the lack of an event is curious
but hopefully we'll have a bigger one
involving these characters
in the near future in season 4 which is
officially called
nexus war thor arrives on the fortnite
island and summons several other marvel
characters
wolverine iron man groot storm
and other characters at first the
fortnite and the marvel characters
confront each other but soon they find
out that there's a greater threat
and everyone then teams up to combat the
season's real antagonist
galactus the map itself has not been
dramatically overhauled
but there are plenty of new marvel
themed locations to visit unlocking
over the course of the season you can
explore areas such as doom's domain
and the sentinel graveyard the season
trailer even shows a shield helicarrier
and there will be other areas that have
yet to be specified
i'm still holding out hope for the
avengers tower
a dramatic change compared to past
seasons is that the nexus war will
not be playable on an apple device epic
games released a statement specifying
players on ios and mac os devices will
be left behind on chapter 2 season 3
while everyone else jumps into the
chapter 2 season 4 launch
if you play on an ios device you can
still play fortnite
but you will be stuck on season 3's
13.40 version
if you own an android device you can
play season 4 if you download it from
the epic game store directly
rather than google play the reason for
this is due to some hefty drama between
epic games
and the apple and google app stores as
epic recently tried to undercut the
purchasing of v-bucks
by having players pay them directly
rather than through the app stores
time will tell if ios users will ever
get the chance to play the current build
of fortnite
[Music]
now plenty of weapons have been vaulted
or unvaulted but there are also some
brand new weapons
the most notable weapon in season 4 is
the stark industries energy rifle
found nearby the quinjets that land
around the island you can pick up the
energy rifle by killing one of the
robots around the jets
stark industries also has supply drones
flying around the map
allowing you to acquire various powerful
weapons and even superhero abilities
fortnite's legendary battle pass system
is back with some
absolute mint rewards the weekly
challenge system returns
letting you gain extra xp and rewards
but the new top tier skin that unlocks
at level 100 of the battle pass
is the iron man skin there are also
wolverine theme challenges that you can
chip away at over the course of the
season
similar to how aquaman worked in season
3. now we'll have plenty more features
and weekly guides to help you rank up to
the season 4 battle pass super quick
so be sure to tune in to our gamespot
and gamespot gameplay youtube channels
for all your fortnite updates thanks for
watching
you